I've just been told this is exciting the
two of New York's hottest Broadway stars
are here they want to say hello please
welcome stars of the hit Broadway show
oh hello
Gil faizon in charge
[Applause]
yeah yeah
they catch
or should we say the other time - you
forgot it yeah I think we all got it
guys thank you so much for coming it's a
real treat
now it's our pleasure we were already up
here taping our prank show
Express train where we tell white people
that the train is local but really it's
an Express you know we're Upper West
Side guys Conan so us coming here is
like a reverse Diff'rent Strokes because
we went from Manhattan to Harlem also we
did cacain first and then became active
again it was very nice very nice very
nice now I see you brought gifts with
you rather do you see something say
something yeah this is our welcome back
to New York official best you can basket
right here yeah
this is this is the basket that Kevin
Hart goes hot-air balloon very nice and
he wasn't here he's not here to respond
but we got you a cornucopia of New York
mementos well thank you very very much
welcome you're welcome welcome you know
it's great it's a great full of all this
great stuff like this official New York
City Street umbrella pre-broken look we
scoured cunnin we scoured every place on
it diamond we scoured every pizza place
in New York to find the most Sun faded
photo of Danny Aiello we also got you
snack in case you get hungry on the
subway you know you know exposing
yourself to women and the subway can
make you pretty hungry so do that no I
know that's us now it's worth your melon
that's been in the fridge for three
weeks so that when you eat it it's like
spice okay I expect
look at this we got you a copy of
Fagin's New York yeah I think you mean
Fodor's New York yeah
no no this is a guide to a favorite NYC
spot to Steely Dan's Donald Fagen okay
they know all the hot tourist things
like going ice-skating on Anthony
Weiner's weird smooth look you know if
you want to do some shopping we got you
a gift certificate to that cemetery that
you see on the way to look War dia get
anything you want
yeah thank you thank you so just do what
it was that gave you a little kiss you
[Applause]
like them you shouldn't you shouldn't do
that that's sad
well thank you very much do you want to
promote your show now oh no no actually
we want to promote our hot new ticket
sales company stump hub yes this is not
to be confused with the dating site for
para please I'll forget you like you
didn't know what was gonna go there yeah
did you not okay stump up what kind of
things do you do you sell tickets to I'm
curious incredible stuff big celebrities
you know big shows like Louie Guzman's
new one-man show duck duck goose Oh
[Applause]
he's doing great Wow that's looks good
yeah Ronin have you ever heard of cats
yeah the musical Cats yes well catch is
revived right now on Broadway so we
revived our cats inspired musical pug
and we listened that we were you we
reunited the original 1983 cast of pugs
these are 23 year old pugs and their
hips are shot today they do but listen
they just kind of slide around this
stage while we play music off of a
Bambara of the bus Wow okay
what else you got oh and we have tickets
to the hottest new tourist attraction
for thrill-seekers the Hudson he Hudson
Heat what's that yes for $11 you can
shove a stranger in the traffic
take that DeBlasio you edit every yeah
so what are you guys up to later we have
reservations you guys the area's great
American garbage fire okay all right and
that's a shot yeah that's a shot yeah
but they're not for a few hours so you
know we're just gonna hang here all
right well I think probably you guys
should probably move on I think we know
we can hang here yeah well do you want
to have a seat in the audience maybe
you'd have a seat in the audience
[Applause]
no you can't come on we're on our marks
and the Lighting's nice we want to let
him stay guilt eyes on a george st.
geegland everybody tracy morgan coming
up
[Applause]
you